here we are today and yes as James said
I am now the Jeske director and I'm a
professor in the HDI Institute at
Carnegie Mellon University and I am NOT
a computer scientist my trainings in
design so I do research and practice at
the intersection of design and
technology as James said one of the
things we did at HCI I was to make a
case for design research why it's
different than but equally important to
other kinds of research that happened in
HCI
and today I do research on service
design design for healthcare human robot
interaction and educational games but
today I'm gonna do something a little
bit different and I'm gonna speculate on
my core discipline of design and where
it's going and I want to reflect by
talking about something I saw and heard
recently at a conference a designer
talked about how they solved the
drinking water problem yes they designed
something to bring fresh water to people
worldwide and this I think is a really
interesting example it's true designers
are now working on larger and larger
areas areas like education public policy
and healthcare and it sort of begs the
question what is design doing how is
design changing and I've really been
thinking about this because I'm writing
a book now about this I'm writing about
how design is changing and I'm thinking
about my experience in my Association of
my contributions in this discipline and
I'm thinking about where we can have
impact as a field or simply put what do
designers really do or as Harold Nelson
says what the hell is design so I wanted
to spend a little bit of time setting
the context for design today as we know
our world is changing and in the past
several decades a lot of dire societal
problems have arisen things like the
global aging of our population
environmental warming and other things
and society is beginning to fraction as
people fail to heed warnings like things
like about
things like global warming and we have
to sort of consider what we can do in
our current generation to protect
generations of the future so these
problems aren't simple problems there
are actually systems of problems which
aren't easy to reduce and solve these
are things that herb Simon called wicked
problems or Russell a cough deemed as
messes and so we're also witnessing the
emergence of a new economic reality
while the American economy grows
steadily how the wealth is created and
who possesses it is changing it always
resonates with me when I come to the bay
area and I see the great division
between wealth and poverty this is a
graphic from a recent New York Times
article that shows that a number of
economic indicators are really
problematic things like employment rates
per capita income and GDP and also we're
seeing a lot of changes in international
production and trade so for example if
we take the automotive industry in the
1950s almost all the cars on the road
and the US were produced in the United
States and this is no longer the case I
think the most popular car in the u.s.
is now the Toyota Camry and in many
cases components of foreign cars are
made in the US and vice versa so
production lines and companies are
blending across continents and this is
also true for other kinds of commodities
and other kinds of service companies at
the same time we're seeing the rise of a
service economy we're seeing a change
from a focus in manufacturing to a focus
on service delivery in 2012 the New York
Times reported that the ratio of
products manufactured globally in the
u.s. dropped significantly while the
percentage of services manufactured grew
drastically so this graphic shows how
around 1960 the most largest profitable
companies in the US were goods producing
companies companies like GM Esso and ITT
but then around about 2010 we saw a
switch
at a sea-change and then the largest
most profitable companies in the u.s.
became service producing companies and
so now especially with the advent of
data we see these systems of
interlinking services and that I think
changes how we train designers and how
we think about design in the world at
the same time of course we're facing a
sea change in technology from the
personal computer to the rise of the
Internet from the development of cloud
computing to smartphones wearable
products sensing the advent of 3d
printing augmented and virtual reality
technology has changed at a rapid pace
and so people have benefited greatly
from these technological advancements so
for example email and blogs have really
speeded and changed how we communicate
online learning has provided learning to
a broader set of people than ever and
these in turn make mean that we have
significant societal changes so
healthcare is a huge area where
technology is impacting what people know
and can track about their own health and
behavior so we're seeing this
proliferation of sensing artificial
intelligence of machine learning and
it's taking the form of smart products
so some say advances here are really
about the data and not about AI itself
because AI has been around for a while
but the net result is that the consumer
has a very different experience so this
is an example of a smart product this is
talking Barbie and Mattel actually
bought an AI startup so they could
create a product a doll that talked to
people and remembered conversations
about the people the doll had interacted
with and then sadly we seem to be living
in an increasingly uncivil community so
there's presidential politics there's
random internet comments
there's rude demeaning and salting and
hateful people in society and I can say
personally I witnessed a
shooting in my neighborhood at a
synagogue this year and the impact on
our community was great and research on
the topic of civility has shown that
mental and physical health happiness and
worker productivity are affected
negatively by this behavior and there's
also social contagion around this
behavior which means that when one
person acts in a rude or uncivil way it
usually means that other people are
going to be doing the same so design
thinking as an approach that's been used
for innovating solutions to these kinds
of problems and attempting to respond to
these many changes in society so a quick
internet search of design thinking shows
many definitions including a process for
creative problem-solving a design
methodology that provides a solution
based approach to solving problems and
applying the principles of design to the
way people work and design thinking has
historic precedents and I want to talk
about these a little bit to continue to
set the context for design so Raymond
Loewy formulated the Maya principle
which stands for most advanced yet
acceptable and this was around the time
of 1940 world war ii era the push of
production in the u.s. the push of
products and this idea expressed that
product designs are bounded by
functional limitations but their
acceptance is what is framed by social
expectations so functionally a product
does something but then again there's a
whole nother layer of expectations about
what people are doing the timeless way
of building referred to work in
architecture by Christopher Alexander
and I'm sorry I'm losing my cursor here
there we go and this was work that
expressed how buildings functioned had
to take the users needs into
consideration so again this grew from
architecture and this movement from not
only making buildings that were function
strong but that people would want to
live in and then the Utopia project
which happened around the 1980s really
had a concern in co.design so technology
was changing how people did the layout
of newspapers workers were concerned
about losing their job and project
utopia responded with a code design
process where technologists worked with
workers to empower workers to stay in
the workforce and use technology in new
ways
in 2008 ideos tim brown published a
highly influential article and Design
Thinking in the Harvard Business Review
and a popular book changed by design
Brown talked about design thinking as a
methodology that imbued the full
spectrum of innovation activities with a
human centered design ethos by this he
said I mean that innovation is possible
through a thorough understanding
thorough direct observation of what
people want and need in their lives he
also represented design thinking as a
cycle of inspiration ideation and
implementation made up of sub cycles
involving explorations of the design
space framework development prototyping
evaluation and dissemination of case
knowledge to the rest of the business
world so really he was talking about the
design process the making the futuring
and he defined five personality
qualities of a design thinker which
included empathy integrative thinking
optimism experimentation and
collaboration Brown went on to say that
thinking like a designer will help you
transform the way you develop products
services processes and even strategy and
he positioned Design Thinking as a tool
for imagining and giving form to future
experiences but design thinking was
misunderstood around 2009 and for
example Peter Murr Holt said Design
Thinking is trotted out as a salve for
businesses who need help with innovation
and he argued instead that we need both
engineering or analytical thinking and
I'm thinking to succeed in the business
place and Don Norman who I would
probably credit as making design more
popular in HCI than any one individual
could ever do talked about how the myth
is the designers possess some magical
creative thought processes that places
them above all others and their skills
in creative groundbreaking thought Don
believe that Design Thinking is useful
way that art designers do more than make
things pretty but I also think that
implicit in his message was this notion
that anyone could design go online and
you can find hundreds of blog posts like
this that really hate on design thinking
some of them are not nice at all
although this one comes from a site
called it's nice that and some of them
are very not nice at all and 10 years
later we're still seeing a lot of debate
about this laden term design thinking
and this HBR article from last year this
woman who's a professor of public policy
at NYU really criticized design thinking
she said that there was nothing unique
or new about it and she likened it to a
method from the 1980s that was called
the rational experimental approach to
problem solving and she said that Design
Thinking is a simplified and popularized
version of this method but this author
didn't seem to be aware at all of the
history of design and the many phases of
design thinking such as the design
methods movement or even the way that
herb Simon talked about design so I
really think that Design Thinking has
offered a lot of benefits to the world
and the many forms that it has been
talked about I think that no press is
bad press even at the time that people
have been talking about this and if you
continue to search on design thinking
there's more
more and Shaun told me this morning he
saw yet another article in Harvard
Business Review that I didn't get a
chance to look at but I think the
strengthen Design Thinking in his
approach is this idea of futuring of
inventing a better world than we have
now
a means for fostering a disciplined
imagination about what the future might
be through the invention of products and
services that are desirable technically
feasible economically viable and realize
a preferred state and yes backing out to
the first part of my talk I think
designers need to think about all these
contexts that surround us today and so
while Design Thinking has been great and
it's really pushed the boundaries of our
discipline I'm still thinking back to
that conference where that person
claimed to make a solution for fresh
drinking water and this question still
nags at me do we need something more
than Design Thinking what comes after
design thinking and what I think we need
actually is a thoughtful engagement with
not only thinking but actually design
practice too as it fits in the world
today taking into account history all
the things that we've done already
the future and what it holds an industry
and academia like so I'm evolving this
notion of design leadership because I
think we need to ask questions such as
what do we need to learn to become
designers in an increasingly complex and
volatile area and some researchers like
Harold Nelson who's one of the authors
of the design way have argued that we
need new and deeper kinds of design
scholarship in today's society so one of
my favorite examples of design that led
to radical change is a paper from 2007
about accidental change at a Baptist
Church the title is radical change
accidentally the emergence and
amplification of small change I think
it's a really nice example of design
leadership this paper is about a Baptist
Church
with a white membership that sat in an
african-american community and the
church's gates and doors were locked to
the community and so it created a
barrier and a set of problems and what
happened in this community was that
parishioners decided to offer a free
breakfast to the community and this
began a change eventually the church's
doors were unlocked
the security system was dismantled the
church offices were moved from the back
to the front of the building so that if
anyone walked in off the street they
would be greeted by somebody volunteer
numbers grew and parishioners began to
offer other services to the community
such as free dental and medical care the
membership then became more diverse the
iconography around the church would had
which had been viewed as offensive by
the community was taken down and even at
one point they melted some of these
things forged a chalice and carried it
to a neighboring church and finally the
church was declares a safe zone for
homeless people to come in and sleep in
this paper it goes on to report that
theories of change were unable to
explain how and why change emerged and
the authors believed that because the
change was unintended emergent and slow
that it occurred in destabilizing
conditions and that it was followed by
subsequent actions and thereby resulted
in radical change so I like this case
because because the conditions around
the study neatly mirror the world that
we live in I think it's a microcosm of
what the world has become today a
destabilizing context sets the stage for
the possibility of change a high degree
of tension means that connections
between people and parts of the system
tighten and that amplifying small
changes becomes easy a lack of ego
Librium means that people will emerge
and self organize in a ready fashion and
in this context novel changes are often
more accepted and result in larger
change
and so in this way continuous change
this dynamic interaction of conditions
some intended and some unintended foster
a pattern of change that is radical and
often beneficial to the world so I'm
interested in how we can train designers
to enact radical change in today's world
students want to do this as they focus
on problems of larger and larger
interest and this is a really
challenging question for design teachers
because we know we still need to teach
the basic skills but we want to push the
boundaries at all times
so we want to be able to train students
to do things like identify problematic
situations and this suggests that the
designers judgment is going to play a
role in what problems we pick and what
we decide to improve to become
conversant in ethics this is means that
we need a big turn and how we design and
what we teach especially in the face of
abundant data in people doing things
with our designs that we never intended
and autonomous things we need to train
our students to be positioned to do
societal good and this means we that we
need to think about the application of
our work and failure cases for the work
we need to train students to have
careers not vocations this means
training them beyond their first job and
knowing that the industry is going to
change and then to really think about
design as leadership this is to train
designers for a long life of work where
they look at design as an action of
change a social and collaborative
process a way to move people to
consensus and to move people towards an
improved future State so right now I'm
thinking about these skills in a
three-part framework empathy
communication and problem reframing and
so I argue to build empathy we want to
teach to our students a way of seeing to
build communication we want to teach our
students away
of abstracting and to look at how to do
problem reframing we want to train our
students how to do design judgments or
to develop a way of lifting up what they
think is important so the first part of
the design leadership framework is
empathy and basically this is the idea
of seeing a situation from many
viewpoints and this is actually
something I have to do as a department
head every day really been able to use
this skill in my leadership of my
department and there's two notions here
the first notion connotes an
understanding of others and in design we
talked about putting designers within a
system and checkland called this a soft
system this is where designers are
really acting as a part of the
environment a part of the problem and it
connotes the second notion which is that
of serving so there's this philosopher
remin who wrote a short paper on serving
versus helping versus fixing and I
always give this to my students to read
helping connotes that the helper is of a
higher status than the person they're
helping and fixing connotes that there's
something that's broken but serving is
really about value sharing being on the
same level and looking at a system
holistically and I think this is really
really important so
[Music]
to continue with empathy in a way of
seeing I think that we need to train
designers to treat communication as both
a process and an object of design and to
regard communication as a process of
developing empathy and to regard
communication as an activity of
structuring and shaping discourse so for
example we could use design as a tool
for creating communication products that
would affect domains ranging from
entertainment to justice from plans to
policy to information and interaction
and we could use communication as a
mechanism to understand and talk about
what it means to be inside one of these
soft systems so I want to deviate for a
few minutes and give a little bit of an
example so one way that we really
exercise this way of seeing was looking
at our work with CMU simón initiative
this was an initiative named for herb
Simon as you know he was on the faculty
at CMU and he was a Nobel laureate I had
the opportunity to take his class did
you James though he was amazing and this
project was set up at CMU to sort of
foster cross-disciplinary learning at
the intersection of Technology so how
are we going to train people using
online learning tools in a way that
makes them competent and able to
participate in society to today and as
you can see one of the statements in the
strategic vision which was developed
said by 2025 Carnegie Mellon students
will be well versed in writing and
communication so we really began to
think about this we had this initiative
where projects were spanning things like
educational data mining and machine
learning but at the same time we're
talking about writing and communication
that seems really really different and
what we began to realize as we immersed
in this context of our campus is that
there's a lot of siloing on campus so we
return to this idea and the strategic
plan and they wanted to use design and
communication to help people coordinate
and think holistically across this
multi-tiered Simon initiative and that's
why I was asked to join the project so a
quick survey of CMU is that we have 28
academic units and I would say about 420
about 25 of them the first language is
math right people are learning
engineering and core technology skills
and students are focused on getting that
first job they are stressed out and they
are on a mission to succeed from the
time they enter as a freshman until they
leave and so there isn't a lot of space
where writing in the curriculum
undergrads and grad students take one
writing course and they never revisit
communication again in their former
curriculum yet communication feeds into
a career trajectory and makes an
important part of a leadership role so
the vision we created used design as a
mechanism to create a communication
platform and I'm not going to go over
this in a lot of detail but basically
what we did was we did a giant survey of
what was going on using design
methodology and then we suggested as a
solution a comprehensive physical and
virtual place informed by expertise in
communication pedagogy the learning
Sciences and Technology so we were able
to bring a way to bundle these things
together and offer a full inventory of
communication skills offered at CMU not
only for students but for people who had
to teach for people who were teaching
engineering who might realize that this
is also important so these services
would be accessible to faculty students
staff academic advisors and even a plan
for alumni so the components of the
platform again I'm not going to go
through this in a lot of detail but for
students we offer things like a
communication skills audit personalized
learning guides one of the things we
learned was that in such a siloed place
there are a lot of resources that nobody
knows about and nobody can make sense of
and use so bringing them in one place is
important a digital portfolio with human
and machine learning that not only
serves as an archive of what a
has done but serves as a data source for
us to evaluate how are people using
these skills and how is it benefiting
them in their careers a suite of
Technology enhanced learning
environments for instructors to
incorporate so they would address their
anxieties about not remaining current
and what they're teaching but then we
also realize that we needed a physical
place for those who are interested in
incorporating communication activities
into their classes and this would serve
as a symbol that we were serving the
community by having a physical place
where people could go and interact and
ask questions so this is a schematic of
what we designed but returning to design
as communication here I was brought to
the project initially - asked and asked
to simply design a website about this
platform but my design work was quickly
recognized as a method to assist in the
design of this organization and I then
became one of a team of four people that
reported to upper administration about
what we should be doing here we had two
faculty from the English department and
a learning science researcher and me and
we also had an anthropologist studying
our team so a lot of the elements in our
solutions already existed and the idea
was to bring them together in a holistic
fashion of course we received a lot of
hesitancy and people pushing back around
our work so what we did mostly was we
served inside of the system we listened
and we promoted and we made connections
and we helped people to see that what we
were creating was something that people
would enjoy and want to participate in
rather than viewing it as another layer
of red tape so the second part of the
design leadership framework is
communication and I think of
communication of as all the artifacts
designers use to make the future
tangible for multiple stakeholders so
these can include ideas sketches
prototypes and pitches but also things
like seeking patterns looking for
commonalities and techniques that maybe
shape the possibilities for
communication so some research
has offered the idea that the
relationship between interaction and
communication which is a central problem
for communication theory it is also a
problem for design so to address this
need for communication I suggest that we
infuse design leaders with new ways of
abstracting so designers use abstraction
to shift from a problem-solving frame to
a negotiation or a solution making frame
and designers rely on both verbal and
visual abstraction so verbal abstraction
can be the use of things like metaphor
analogy and visual abstraction really is
about the use of conceptual models much
after the work that hue EE does so I've
been teaching conceptual modeling to my
students for over 10 years now and I
hear again and again when I visit with
alumni that this is one of the most
important skills that they've learned in
their work so this is an example from
the conceptual models project at CMU
what we have people do is we have them
do a concept map where they lay out all
the themes relative to situation and
then we have them do a conceptual model
where they abstract that information
away to show something that's important
for an audience so this is a sketch
that's about people in Oklahoma a
student did and he shows the three types
of people and then he shows us in a
smaller circle the people that he wants
to interact with so this is kind of
tongue-in-cheek II but it's a really
nice model it's actually a Venn diagram
and it it summarizes the situation the
societal situation that the designer
wants to talk about here's another one
can you tell what this one is
don't count your chickens before they're
hatched right so this is a flow diagram
circular flow you go back you're
counting are they hatched no and when
they're hatched you stop counting so
again a beautiful abstraction of a
situation helps the designer to clarify
their thinking helps to communicate a
situation and then here's another one
with a clean abstracted visual design
the student has conveyed choosing the
perfect bike on Craigslist if you live
in San Francisco so the third part of
the design leadership framework is
problem reframing so this is looking at
a problem and interpreting it in new
ways this is a key characteristic of
design thinking and I think if there's
one thing that we teach people about
design this is probably the thing that
they should carry away so abstraction is
one process for doing this but we can
also look at other processes like
metaphor analogy and conjecture
so there's many barriers enables to how
enable errs to help people frame
problems we can be fixated we can have a
constrained mental model we can have
resistance remember the people in the
assignment initiative fell resistance
until we found a way to lift up and work
around their limitations and thinking
about what the future could be and then
we have enablers like models engaging
other aspects of context looking at
conjecture essentially turning things
around so to address a need for problem
reframing I suggest that we infuse
design leaders with a way of lifting up
we can use problem framing to develop a
set of possible actions to advance
towards a design solution and we can use
reframing as a process of adopting new
frames to interpret design context we
can bring our values as designers to the
frames that we use to change and work
with these problems of course they are
valued Laden but they can change based
on one's experience of design so I also
think that part of education is
offering a broad perspective about
society giving people waypoints to
understand and find and this is
something that was lacking in my own
design training these concepts are
really difficult to teach so I think the
best way to do it is to use a master and
apprentice approach and so as one
example of design framing I want to talk
about my colleague John Zimmerman's work
on decision support tools and implanting
heart devices a VAD is a mechanical
heart device which is often implanted in
a patient as a last resort to keep them
alive and almost all decision support
tools for these devices fail when they
move from lab to clinic many of these
patients who receive implants die soon
after surgery and additionally
cardiologists who implant these devices
don't think they need decision support
tools they think they have enough
knowledge to make the decisions on their
own so the challenge here was to design
a decision support tool to decide when
to implant a VAD and to do it in a way
that improves medical outcomes and would
be one that clinicians would accept and
use so mission impossible so the team
took a design approach they did design
focus field work at clinical sites they
interviewed an observe many stakeholders
to identify the opportunities for
integrating decision support they looked
at rounds they looked at meetings they
looked at hallway conversations and they
synthesized this work using affinity
diagrams and service blueprints and so
this was a little bit of what they found
they identified basically three patient
pathways that could lead to the implant
of one of these devices
the first is emergent patients come in
very sick there's no time for a decision
support tool the patient goes to sleep
and they wake up with a VAD usually the
family is doing the consenting not the
individual themselves so here there's no
time or use for a decision support tool
the second is a typical cyclical decline
the patient gets better and worse better
and worse and they keep advancing
stronger drugs and then when the drug
stopped working the VAT is implanted and
then the third is a late referral
sometimes patients get referred too late
to the cardiologist team they're too
sick for surgery but they begged for the
VAD anyways and this points to I think
this need for a decision support tool
upstream to get to these kinds of
patients so remember that these doctors
did not want to have AI they did not
want to have a decision support tool at
all and so what the design team did was
they reframed and they ended up
embedding this technology and a
PowerPoint slide generator this was
great because it fit with how the
cardiology cardiologists routinely did
their work they have rounds and they use
PowerPoint slides this came from the
research team as a result of reframing
and pivoting and repurposing how AI
might work with a decision support tool
that might benefit how these
cardiologists work this system doesn't
interrupt what clinicians do nor does it
detract from the way that they make
decisions so what they did was they put
a confidence score you can see in the
lower left in the orange box this was a
small indication of how the AI was
working and so slowly over time these
clinicians could begin to look at this
score understand how the AI was working
in the background and developed trust
and fluency with the system
so to recap today I introduced the
three-part design leadership framework
empathy communication and problem
reframing I suggested that to build
empathy we need to develop a way of
seeing to build communication we should
develop a way of abstracting and to
build design judgments we need a way to
reframe problems or to lift up so in my
work I want to improve the very nature
of design itself being a designer starts
right after the decision to become one
on day one so design leadership I think
should be a formal part of any designers
training
and here I've tried to introduce some
ideas about how we might get there my
intention is to make design more
systemic holistic understandable
accessible and relevant to people who
are both practicing and doing research
around design so I hope to hear some
questions from you and to help along in
this mission with your effort so thank
you for listening today
[Applause]